Everyone loves music.
Well, not everyone.
What's up with people who don't care about
music?
I'm Anthony Carboni, this is DNews, and about
five percent of the population just isn't
into music.
The other ninety-five percent think they're
weird- almost to the point of distrusting
them.
But is there something wrong with them or
just our reaction to them?
A study out of the University of Barcelona
attempted to figure out what sort of person
isn't into music.
There's a known condition called "Amusia"
in which people just can't process music-
they don't understand pitch, they can't remember
or recognize a song.
It can be something someone is born with or
something that comes from damage to the brain.
There's no one actual music center in the
brain, so it's usually damage to the audio
cortex or some of the memory or logic processing
areas.
You might say "oh, okay, that solves it- people
who don't like music just have a case of weirdbrain."
But amusia doesn't account for everyone who's
not into music.
The Barcelona study looked at these people
with healthy minds and no love for melody
and had them try a few things to elicit an
emotional response.
They listened to and rated music.
Then they were asked questions and given a
range of small monetary rewards if they gave
a correct answer.
The idea was to check the reward center of
the brain, which shows high activity when
most people listen to music- and when they
get free money.
Because reward center.
Anyway, these people seem to have reward systems
that function just fine- there's nothing wrong
or different about them.
They just literally don't like music.
The researchers call it "specific musical
anhedonia"- an inability to experience pleasure
from music.
So: why do others think they're weird?
We know that people have different interests
than us.
Asking around the office, I found that people
were fine if someone didn't like TV, or sports,
or reading, or a bunch of other activities.
But no one seemed to be cool with people who
didn't enjoy music- or food.
Now, we've discussed a lot of our ingrained
tendencies to seek out and trust people with
similar traits before.
It's a safety and survival thing from our
tribal past- people who think the way we do
make easier and safer companions because there's
less chance of stress and disagreements.
Even babies tend to shun people they think
are different in some way.
But why the huge distrust and disbelief when
it comes to music and food?
This is conjecture, but food's required for
survival and there's a community aspect to
it- early societies built around the sharing
of it, and now our cultural clocks are built
around meal breaks and family dinners.
It's not just linked to physical survival,
it seems to have a link to social survival.
Maybe it's so built into us on a basic level
that we distrust people who say they don't
love it.
even though in our society where most places
have enough food and obesity is an issue,
not feeling strongly about food might be the
healthier attitude.
A paper published last year by the University
of Colorado says music might have a similar
social component in our development as a species.
The researchers say that music was a form
of social communication- a way to signal a
group's shared mental state.
The study showed people who more strongly
feel a need to belong also feel a stronger
emotional connection to music.
It could be people are so confused by someone
who doesn't care about music because it signals
that person as an outlier fundamentally- sort
of like food.
Like I said, that's more me thinking out loud
than anything else.
But as it stands, 5% of the population isn't
into music- and it seems like nothing's physically
different about most of them.
Any ideas on why we're so put-off when people
aren't into music?
Let me know down below and subscribe for more
DNews.